All I've got to do is train Justin AI now and just have him show up on the podcast and
be like, guys, look at this bug, you know, and then my hand is going to glitch out and
you know, it's going to like go through my face or something.
Best math of acting when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
Oh, yeah, dude.
All right, man, let's roll.
Um, we'll see if my voice holds up today.
Somehow I got a cold again.
Uh, so yeah, I'm going to be like muting and, you know, hacking up along on the side.
See what I did there?
Hacking up along.
Oh, I did not catch that.
That's awesome.
I should have given you that.
I did not even catch it.
It's such a common expression.
I never even thought I'd have a Nord hacking in it.
Yeah.
Um, so yeah, it should be an interesting.
episode, but, um, let's go ahead and jump into a couple announcements.
First, first thing was that we are updating our, um, crit research lab
exclusivity agreement.
So for any of you all that have been submitting awesome research to the crit
research lab, thank you guys so much for that.
Um, we are changing our agreement a little bit to be a little bit more, uh, liberal
here, a little bit more, um, in favor of the researcher where previously we, um, requested
that the researchers would not take the material and hosted anywhere else.
Leave it on this, on the research lab website.
We are now, um, giving the researchers the ability to host it on their own blog as well
after 30 days is up.
So, um, if that exclusivity agreement was a, um, you know, deciding factor for you in not
submitting research to the lab, then, uh, please go ahead and check out the new agreement.
Uh, as I think this would help a little bit.
Um, and, and for those of you that aren't familiar with it, uh, this is a essentially
crowdsourced research lab that we're doing where we will pay researchers for their research,
um, and hosted on the lab, cover it on the pod, that sort of thing.
So lots of extra distribution and you also get, you know, we try to buy them dinner at least,
you know, for, for the research that they do.
So if that interests you, definitely check it out.
Um, lab.ctbb.show.
And there's been a lot of good research on there.
Hasn't there, man?
Yeah, it's insane.
And I, I think that, uh, Justin might be, uh, filling his own, uh, desires here.
Cause like, I think that what has been lacking, well, not necessarily lacking, but one thing you
see less of, and it's because people are a little bit insecure of like, is this research worthy?
Is this post worthy or whatever is you encouraging people to basically post like
even just gadgets like, Hey, if you have this weird functionality in this and like in the browser
or in this other thing, like just go ahead and post it and share it with us.
And then it ends up being a, like a core component of a chain later on.
Yeah, totally.
And, and actually I'm glad you mentioned that dude, because right before this episode,
you and I were talking about an exploit, um, sort of gadget that I'm going to use in a bug
that I've got right now.
And this put came up in the critical thinkers chat, um, which is just yet another reason you
guys should, should subscribe to the critical thinkers here because there's just so much gold
that goes into that chat.
Um, but one of the guys in there dropped that, um, if let's say you have like an open redirect,
uh, and, but you only control the, the, um, you know, the, the protocol specific portion there.
Um, you can do some really interesting stuff with popping it into, uh, what is, uh, let me pull up the
actual thing it's X dash or safari dash HTP S slash dash X, isn't it?
Or did I get it mixed around?
Uh, I don't know the syntax exactly, but I'd also use this for a vulnerability on an engagement
a few months ago and it was awesome.
It's really neat.
Um, you can use it for AI vulnerabilities specifically if their protection, um, is using
sec fetch sites.
So yeah, it's a X dash safari dash HTP S.
Okay.
So what's interesting is that also ends in HTP S, uh, which is, which is nice for.
Gold for rejects.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So you can pop it open into a different browser, um, which is helpful for leaking stuff sometimes.
And also, uh, it gets you into safari, which may have different client side restrictions
than you'll see in your, um, other environments.
Um, so that, that's a pretty cool little, little trick.
That's a perfect example of something that, uh, you know, we would love to have microblogged
on the lab website.
Uh, so if you guys are interested in checking out the lab, please do that.
Um, okay.
So we do have a little bit of news to get into today, uh, before we get into the episode,
I will like let the hunters know, you know, one of the, one of the core tenants of CTPV is that
every episode we're trying to give S tier hunters, you know, at least one little tidbit of knowledge
that will further their, um, hacking skills.
This episode is actually an AMA focused on, um, bug bounty.forum, which is a new environment
that we're trying to support and help hack, you know, hackers migrate to, uh, where we can talk
about all things bug bounty.
So we decided to do an AMA on it.
A lot of the stuff we're going to be answering today is pretty basic stuff.
There, there is some more nuanced stuff in there as well, but, uh, I do like to give that little,
you know, uh, announcement in the beginning, just in case any of you more advanced
hunters would just like to stick around for the, for the new segment today.
Um, that being said in the new segment, I'm going to cover a super sick technique that I
think every, uh, you know, top tier hunter should know about.
So a minute ago, Justin was literally just staring off into space and I thought he was
thinking about how to, uh, like, I don't know, get these AMA questions lined up, right.
Or thinking about an answer to one of the AMA questions.
I was like, Justin, what are you just thinking about?
He's like, I'm thinking about how awesome this, this, this write-up is.
Dude, it's so good, man.
I, I love cross site leaks so much.
Um, so anyway, there's your, there's your announcement, um, beforehand, uh, to let you
know, um, we're going to dump, jump right into this, uh, write-up.
This is cross site E T or E tag length leak.
Um, and this is by arc arc, uh, who I believe is actually a Japanese researcher, which is cool.
Um, I see some of the, the Japanese in his, uh, in his screenshots here.
Uh, yeah, I think that's.
I want to say that's whole goal.
Sorry to deny sushi.
It's like unprotected.
Uh, so I, yeah.
HPS is not HPS.
Um, but anyway, I wanted to cover this, um, this write-up because I think this is a really cool
cross site leak and it shows what is possible with just a little.
Little modification, um, and being able to leak just one extra bite.
Um, so let me go ahead and jump into this.
Uh, this was a, a CTF challenge for, uh, sec con, um, and it was authored by arc arc.
Uh, and it takes a bunch of different primitives here on how to leak the flag cross origin.
So the first thing that's interesting is the E tag header length.
And, um, one of, one of the very, uh, cool pieces about, uh, the E tag is that a lot of
times it's implemented using a hex string.
Okay.
So sometimes depending on the size of the response, um, I'll, I'll read this, uh, here,
this quote from the, um, from the article, it says, because the size is encoded in hex,
the number of hex digit changes at boundaries.
For example, zero X F F goes to zero X 1000, right?
Which has four characters rather than three.
This means the ET, uh, or the E tag length can differ by one, depending on whether the response
size crosses such a boundary.
Um, so, uh, in this specific challenge, we control the response size by abusing CSERF to
create many notes in the victim session.
And this allows us to manipulate the total response size so that if you, if you create
a search hit, it, it has a, you know, it crosses that boundary and makes the E tag one longer.
And if you search, you know, and had the response, uh, the miss response, then it will be, uh,
a shorter length in the E tag header here.
Um, and, uh, that is just freaking sick, man.
Um, and, and the way that this works is when you, when you send a search,
the, the site will return the E tag header.
Right.
And then when you send that same, um, search again, that, that, um, value that's in the E tag
header will then be placed into the, um, if none match header right here.
Right.
So, so the value from that original, uh, E tag response header, which contains, you know,
that, that byte that could be one longer or not longer gets put into the request.
Right.
And then what, what they use here is they use, um, the four 31 status code error,
which is a part of no JS.
Right.
Which says that I know dude, isn't this crazy.
This is absurd.
Right.
So if you, if you nudge your request right up to this, um, 16 kilobyte limit on the size of
headers, which includes the request, um, uh, like query.
So you can pad a bunch in the, in the, like an X square parameter, whatever, then that the,
the differential between that one bite that gets put in the E tag header will result in a 431,
which would indicate a, a hit versus, uh, you know, a 200, which would indicate a miss.
Right.
And this is, you know, uh, a, a browser functionality here that, uh, you know, obviously
the server is returning the 431, but the browser functionality that we use to determine the difference
is, uh, whether or not that, that 431 is actually placed into the browser history or not.
Because the history API, right.
Has this function called should replace current entry and where it, it decides between pushing
into the history versus replacing the current entry.
And if it is a, a 431, um, then that's going to be, you know, replaced versus if it's an actual
navigation at 200, right.
Then it will, uh, be added to the history.
Mm-hmm
Right.
So if you're, if your history length is one shorter, even cross origin, you can tell whether
it was a 431 or a 200, right.
Which allows you to get a yes, no answer on whether a search hit or didn't hit.
And then using that, you can binary search and brute force all the characters of the flag
cross origin with a cross site.
That's ridiculous.
Did anyone.
How sick is that?
Did it say it was solved one time?
Let me see.
Hold on.
Let's see.
It said like difficulty one of 5,000.
One solve.
Crazy dude.
Um, I just, I just love that this uses just a one bite difference in the length of a header.
Right.
To leak an entire flag.
To leak the flag.
Frick dude.
I love it.
So, um, anyway, I hope that explanation made sense.
Um, I'll go ahead and try to summarize it here at the end.
Um, the, the E tag header, which is returned from the server will be one bite longer in some
specific scenarios.
Right.
Um, and that value will be reflected into your request the next time you try to hit that endpoint.
To see if there's a cache caching of compatibility here.
Right.
Using that reflected value into the header.
You can determine, uh, you know, yes or no, whether that extra bite was added, uh, by, you know,
cushioning right up to that, uh, 16 kilobyte limit that gives you a 431.
Yeah.
Right.
And if the 431 is returned, then that entry will replace the current entry in, um, in the history
API versus adding to the history API, which then once you navigate back to an origin you control,
you can check the length of the history and determine whether or not it was a 431 or not,
which gives you a yes or no on weather.
I didn't, I didn't, I didn't, I didn't realize the history dot length thing was required too.
Yeah.
That's a really nice, that's a really nice cross site leak primitive.
Um, I've seen that used quite a bit.
Um, so yeah, I guess just kind of taking this to a higher level, dude, like paying attention to
these really small details like that, you know, uh, like just a one bite difference in the encoding of,
of the, of the hex can result in some of these, uh, cross site leaks, which is astounding in my opinion.
Absolutely astounding.
Yeah.
This is, I don't know, like the orange shy of front end.
Seriously.
These CTF guys are insane, man.
Really?
Yeah.
All right.
What you got in the news?
Um, yeah, something small and neat.
Uh, it's called Claudus, um, or maybe it's called Claud.
I'm trying to find the notes.
Yeah.
Claud bot.
Claud.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's kind of confusing.
I'll, we'll put it in the show notes, but there's basically like a guy on X was saying,
Hey, I saw that this other guy named Stipeet was building Claudus.ai and that's C-L-A-W-D-I-S.ai.
And I was intrigued.
So I just told Claud code to stand up Claudus for me and I call it Claudad.
And it did, and it did it all for itself.
And it's basically just like using Claud code, like using like, um, an agent, but from WhatsApp.
And so it feels much more natural.
Like you're like messaging your friend or something like that.
But then he wanted to send an audio message.
So he was like literally in the car or something like waiting for his wife to go get groceries.
And so he sent a WhatsApp audio message and was like, Hey, you know, figured this out, you know?
And so it basically installed whisper CPP via, and like, then use that to listen to his audio
message to then start doing that.
But anyways, I just think that the, being able to control your AI agents from WhatsApp seems really
cool, especially if it's, um, and like, you know, people have built that before, but it's not been
like Claud code under the hood.
And I think Claud code under the hood is really where there's a lot of power.
And I've been using cloud code from a VPS where it can basically play DevOps engineer
for me to like, you know, reconfigure things or stand up POCs or whatever.
And so when I want to mess with it, I always have to like open Termius and like type really
small in a terminal on my phone.
That just sounds really miserable.
Whereas if I could just send an audio message and be like, Hey, like, let's try a new design
on this website, you know, that I'm POC or playing with for just my family or whatever.
Um, and an audio message on like WhatsApp, that feels like it would be much more fun
and clean and good.
And so, um, I thought that was really cool.
You guys can check out, um, that it's just Clawdis, C-L-A-W-D-I-S dot AI.
Nice.
Yeah.
I think that's, I think that's nice to have, you know, especially on your POC server,
you know, adding something to your POC or something like that.
Um, making it a little bit more convenient with text messages or, or, you know, WhatsApp or whatever.
Yeah.
I've been doing, um, hopefully this is not leaking anything.
I've been doing, um, more tracking of those sorts of things.
Actually, I think I did tell you that basically Grok, Grok and Tesla is adding more features.
And so being able to just be a voice test, little payloads and stuff feels like, feels like the future.
You know, it's like, I'm doing prompt injection hacking in my car while I'm driving and similar
things for like Google's adding more and more like, uh, AI, like Gemini to Google maps and directions
and stuff.
And so I think that, um, there's some, there's some really neat room for attacks there that people should try.
So totally, totally.
Yeah.
I think that, I think also I've said in the past, I'm using Gemini CLI more.
I think it's gotta be cloud code, man.
I think a lot of people are saying cloud code is like really, really doing wonderful stuff for them.
And I have been running into some issues lately with Gemini.
So I think even though I kind of, I kind of believe that Gemini will eventually win the whole, like AI thing, you know, or, or be the leader.
Um, I think for the time being, I gotta hop on the, the cloud code train.
So yeah.
When there's no spin up or when there's no like spin up, um, friction and you just start, start using it.
It's like, why not just try out the best one?
And then if you want to switch back to Gemini CLI in a month, it's like, it'll take you an extra 10 minutes
to copy and paste over a prompt or something.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I feel like the switching cost is not very high.
Yep.
Um, all right, man, actually, I'm going to cut this next, um, news item so we can just jump right into the episode.
Cause that cross site e tag leak thing was like, was nuts.
So let's jump right into it.
Um, so like I said before bug bounty dot forum, awesome place.
You guys should check it out.
We, we really would like to support that environment.
Um, and let me tell people, let me tell people just really quickly what it is.
So basically it's an anonymous forum for bug bounty hunters where there's not like it's, it's almost
like stateless in a way you basically get given a U U ID number and you just use that to log in.
You don't have to like even store credentials or anything like that.
And you can't even really edit your profile at the moment.
But one thing that's really neat is you can upload anonymously your bug bounty earnings.
So you, and you know, that's also optional.
You don't have to do it, but if you do do that, then, you know, it's kind of, um,
proof of that validation that, you know, what you're talking about.
You know, if you found a significant number of vulnerabilities or what have you.
And so that's pretty, that's pretty neat.
Um, I think that's makes it kind of like fun and exciting.
And you like, kind of like know who to listen to.
Obviously bug bounty earnings are everything.
We know plenty of people who have made plenty of money from bug bounty that maybe aren't the,
the wisest or the, you know, the, the people you want to necessarily listen to.
But at the very least it's like a really like, Hey, this person at least knows what they're
talking about when it comes to like technical skill or, you know, this person is, is worth
listening to because they've at least dabbled enough and they've submitted enough bugs to
have a good experience with plenty of programs or what have you.
I think that's, I think that's a good representation of the situation.
You know, I, I think at the end of the day, we're in a POC or GTFO industry.
And the, the proof is that you have earnings, you know?
And it's like, it's like Reddit, I guess is one other thing.
It basically you, you upvote and downvote comments and posts.
And, um, so it seems like a nice place and a cool place to like start discussing
things from a bug bounty perspective.
And there's been a lot of people that have migrated over there.
So.
Yeah.
And I think Puma is putting a lot of work into it, um, and shipping new features quickly
and it works well on mobile, which is nice.
So, uh, yeah, cool, cool place.
And we're going to do an AMA from there.
Um, so we selected a bunch of different questions.
Now, um, when we posted the, uh, the AMA, uh, people got really wordy with their, uh, questions,
uh, which was not expected, but as you can see,
a lot of these questions are like super long.
So we took a couple of them and, and, or we took all of them and fed them into AI and kind
of extracted the core question behind, um, a lot of them, but we'll try to also jump back over and,
um, address the actual questions directly, um, as we can.
So I guess how we'll do that, um, Joseph is if one person is, you know, answering it, we can kind
of go back and make sure with the original question, uh, whether we're catching the nature of it.
Does that sound good?
Okay.
Yeah, it sounds good.
Awesome.
So the first one that came up was will bug hunting become obsolete due to AI agents in the next five
or 10 years by Granite Glitcher?
I'll let you take that one, dude.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that the concern here, you know, the person later on in their question,
Granite Glitcher says, you know, if we're being honest in their opinion, it's not a good idea for
newbies to get into this industry.
Howard jr is supposed to stand a chance, you know, et cetera, et cetera.
I don't think that bug bounty is going to be gone in five to 10 years, like not even close,
but I do think that it is going to be more competitive.
So if you're going to get into it, I think you need to make sure that you are kind of supercharged,
right?
And I think that's going to be true across a lot of industries.
AI lowers the barrier to entry to get into, into new fields or like, or just into fields in general.
And then it also lowers the barrier to entry of like going from, Hey, I know a little bit
to, I can do cool stuff.
Right?
Like if you just know a little bit, now you can like work with cloud code or whatever
to build a cool tool or a cool thing.
And you can also, because of the internet and get really quick feedback on like how it's going.
So I would say, you know, should beginners get into bug bounty?
Yeah.
I still think bug bounty is like the, like an overlap of you're going to build real skills
that are valuable to huge corporations.
You are going to, um, build your resume as well.
You know, sometimes you can have skills, but it won't necessarily translate to a resume.
Bug bounty findings do like kind of directly translate to resumes.
Even if all you did was go do all of Portspeaker labs.
Right?
Like being able to say you've done those is like actual real validation of like real
training that you've done.
Um, you, you obviously have the potential for money.
And then it's in an industry where like, if you are able to kind of succeed, it's freaking fun.
Like you get to go on like cool trips and stuff, live hacking events.
Um, and the flexibility, like there's no sales, there's no like meeting of, you know, a lot of
people I think don't love sales or they don't love, you know, face-to-face interactions with customers
or whatever.
So if you're like that type of person and you really want that flexible and free ability
than our freedom and flexibility, then it also has that.
So I would say go into it, but go into it knowing like, Hey, I'm probably going to want to use AI to
supercharge myself.
I'm going to want to build my own tools.
I'm going to want to eventually maybe transition to some like hardware hacking.
Cause I think that'll be more defensible long-term as well.
Yeah, I agree.
I agree with that.
And I think you answered the core of the question.
I will, I will add, I think AI is just another layer of automation on top of it.
And sure, it, it targets a little bit more manual-esque hunting, more than other, you know,
automation breakthroughs that we've had in the past, like cloud and, and, you know, Kubernetes and
stuff like that.
But at the end of the day, it's still a, it's just like another hacker that has their own set of eyes.
Right.
And it's going to miss stuff.
And sure, they can throw it at it a thousand times.
Right.
And maybe that compute will get such that they can do that and, you know, really tweak the temperature
and stuff like that.
But, um, I think it's just going to be another hacker, you know, and there's so many hackers
looking at the same scope.
We find crit after crit after crit on after live hacking event, you know?
And, uh, and so I, I really do think that it is, uh, bug bounty industry is going to be just fine,
especially with all the crappy code written by AI to help balance out the table, you know?
Yeah.
The number of people who are developing apps these days is like way higher.
So like you said, there's also going to be way more opportunities for vulnerabilities.
And I would just, and I would just say this, like.
If bug bounty goes away, almost every industry is going away.
And at that point, you know, like we're just in like a different situation as a society.
Right.
It's like, we need to solve this with UBI or whatever, you know, or maybe we'll be flourishing
or maybe it will be some huge, great depression, but it's not going to uniquely negatively impact bug bounty.
It's going to impact a lot more if, if, and when that does ever happen.
But I think it'll be slow and gradual.
And I think that it'll be fine.
So yeah, I agree, man.
Um, let's move on to some of these questions by furious beacon.
Uh, which ones you think is best?
Just here.
Let me ask you, I think, um, it's a good question.
What are ways to get invited to a live hacking event?
If you're not a top tier hacker, Justin?
Um, well, the live hacking events are kind of for the top tier hackers.
Uh, there, there are some, like, I don't know how hacker one selects these, but I have seen
like some mentees that get to come to the live hacking events.
I think they're normally like local hackers.
Um, I guess the, the short answer to this would be specialize in one program.
That, that has live hacking events, you know, scour.
And that, that was a later question.
Like what companies run live events?
So we can tell them kind of.
Yeah.
Which types of companies it's usually.
Let's leave that as a exercise delicitor.
Cause sometimes they don't want us to talk about them.
No, no, no, no.
I was gonna talk about it as a category.
It's basically large companies that are able to afford live hacking events.
Yeah.
Like, you know, you're going to be looking at more at like within the, within the fortune 20,
let's say there's going to be, you know, five or 10 companies there that are running
live hacking events.
Um, and so I think, you know, targeting these like larger companies that can afford to buy
live events and getting in their good graces is a great way to get invites.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think that's pretty much the only way if you're not like a generally top tier hacker,
the best way is going to be to specialize in one program and get invited as a specialist.
I do think you can, um, and please don't blow
people up.
But if you're adding values with a lot, that's different.
I would say, I think another good way is to become good friends with somebody who gets
invited a lot and, and, and, you know, ask for a plus one.
And, and the best way to do that is to send them high quality leads, high signal leads.
Don't mention them and say, Hey, or say hi or say whatever.
But if you have like a lead that you.
You know, think could be either escalated from like a medium to a crit or whatever,
or you have a, uh, you know, a higher crit.
That's like almost a bug that, but that you can't get past like a specific thing or whatever.
If you send that to bug hunters that, you know, are going to live events and you develop a
relationship with them where you guys are collabing on the regular, then when they're
invited, they would probably be open to giving you a plus one.
I have heard of lots of hackers, including me and, um, including Douglas, um, including others who
basically were a plus one at an event.
They did well.
And then they got more invites.
So that's probably.
I was a plus one of a plus one.
Yeah.
Yeah, totally, man.
I agree.
And, and I will echo what you said, like giving, you know, like coming to a more
experienced hacker with an actual bug is like, you know, the best way for us to know that
you're not playing around, you know, cause we get so many DMS like, Hey, is this vulnerable?
Is this like, you know, HTML injection vulnerable or whatever?
And I'm like, dude, come on.
But if you're like, Hey, here's this, uh, you know, XSS with CSP bypass, I'm, you know,
like, I need this one little thing to make it work.
You know, any idea how to do this?
Then I'm going to be a lot more likely to like, okay.
Yeah.
This guy kind of knows what he's talking about, you know?
Or another thing is actually kind of saying, Hey, I just found this new host.
I'm like, Hey, I'm like, I'm going to go to the next one.
I'm going to go to the next one.
And I'm going to go to the next one.
Then I'll be able to do that.
And I'll go find the host and that sort of thing.
Very rarely am I scanning these extra domains.
It's just not what I found the most signal from in my opinion.
Yeah, fair enough.
OK, let's see.
Next one.
You could ask me number seven if you want.
OK, let me ask you this.
Is it better to do bug bounty full time
or treat it like a nine to five job with fixed hours?
Yeah, I would say as a as a father
or as a person with like other obligations,
like maybe you're taking care of your parents
or maybe you do have a full time job.
I definitely think time boxing is the way to go
from a lifestyle design perspective.
But that's not going to get you the types of results
if you're trying to level up.
So when I was getting into bug bounty,
it felt like it was all I thought about.
It was all I worked on.
It was like in the evening.
It was all I did.
It was like I was falling asleep at my computer.
Literally, like I was laying in bed with my laptop
on my thing and I would wake up with it in my lap
because, you know, it required that kind of passion
to get into for success.
But, you know, now because I'm a full time hunter,
I do time box it to, you know, basically eight to five
or eight to four thirty and that works for me.
And we do we do that pretty aggressively, I think.
And and and I think that, you know,
I guess it remains to be seen for you.
But for me, I think that is one of the things
that's contributed to the longevity of my full time
bug bounty hunting career is is that you do have,
you know, healthy boundaries and stuff like that.
So, yeah, I mean, I think this is traditional advice
you see on like hustle Twitter.
But, you know, in the beginning,
you need to put in some freaking hours
and you need to get good at something
and you need to hustle.
And then as you get good at something,
the way that you stay in the game is you
adopt something that gives you longevity.
And I'll actually even call out.
I'll call out a couple of hunters that that that I know.
Like Franz is one of the guys that that always really amazes me with this.
Like, you know, he goes so hard.
He goes so hard on hunting.
But even now, like I see him put up boundaries with his hunting,
you know, even as one of the one of the the more like,
just go ham until you die, you know,
hunters that I've ever met, you know,
he does have to put up boundaries with his hunting to make sure that he,
you know, has longevity.
Um, so I think it's a non-negotiable for, for, for full-time hunters to,
to have some sort of like,
I guess, structure to it.
Yeah, yeah.
And I'll add one more thing at the end here,
which is that that really golden nugget from the Franz episode
that we did a while back, which was that,
you know, he says, close the laptop, right?
When you're about to found find something.
And I'm like, dude, what is wrong with you, man?
Like that is hacked.
But oftentimes I do, I do find myself doing that nowadays where I'm like,
okay, wow.
I just found like this sick little like sub app on a website.
That's got a bunch of extra routes.
And I'm like really excited to hit it.
And I'm like, you know what?
I'm gonna do that tomorrow.
You know?
And I'm just like clawing at my desk to get back to it the next day.
Yeah.
I think that's really smart.
I don't know if I have the,
I don't know if I have the self-control to do it though.
Yeah.
It does take some for sure.
But I think you've done a good job of that this year.
Yeah.
In your, in your first year of full-time bug bounty.
I appreciate it.
I was surprised you highlighted this question.
So I want to ask you this one.
It says, what's better 10 bugs at five grand or one bug at five grand?
Yeah.
I mean, I think 10, 10 bugs at five grand total should clarify that.
Yes.
Or finding one bug at five grand.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah, I, I wanted to actually kind of debate this with you a little bit
and see what you think.
I mean, obviously I personally think the one bug at five grand is better, right?
Like I just, cause one report, you know, obviously it's a more impactful bug,
that sort of thing.
but also like there's a momentum aspect you know like would i rather find 10 bugs and get five five
grand out of it you know especially as a beginner that might feel really good yeah you know and it
might suggest it might give you more intel on what this program is vulnerable to yeah right like okay
i've got 10 bugs i've got a pretty good profile of like okay this program's vulnerable to this to
this to this to this to this right yeah i mean i think personally if you just think about it from
like a business you like we we it's funny we use this word off air earlier but it it definitely
de-risk you to find more bugs at a lower value yeah um you have a smoother income earning curve
um but there's no doubt that there's more prestige and skill required to find critical bugs
and there's no doubt that companies care more about those writ large in regards to invites in regards to
respect that you have from them in regards to like kudos and thanks and all those things so
you know i think if you had to answer that question you knew you were going to get both
you would do one bug at 5k but the thing is most people don't know they're going to necessarily do
that i'm a big fan of you know report all the bugs unless they're unless that's a hundred dollar bug or
you know an open redirect or something i think i'm a big fan of people you know submitting all the bugs
yeah yeah i agree with that overall i think so i i think the answer to this i mean at first glance you
would look at this and be like obviously the one bug at 5k but i actually think it really depends it
depends on where you're at in your bug bounty journey it depends on your relationship with this target
right like if this if this is a live hack event target per se or for example i i might take the
the 10 10 at 5 at 5k total because it gives me a better profile of what this company is vulnerable
to and i'm going to be like going ham on this company you know for for the next like you know two
weeks yeah and it is hard to say what's more valuable in the minds of the people because like
um this is just like me talking about my heuristics a little bit my heuristics say that at hacker one
live hacking events volume matters and at google ai life hacking events criticality matters when it
comes to getting mvh let's say yeah um like the last the last you know a couple google events i
heard like like three out of four of them the mvh is the person they found the most critical bug
whereas it seems like a lot of times mvh at google or at hacker one events are often people who got the
most bugs yeah it is interesting though because at these google live hacking events you'll often see
like only one or two mega crits yeah you know like yeah like oh crits you know whereas i feel
like at a lot of hacker one live hacking events like regardless of the target there's a couple you're
you're seeing like like you know most everybody's got one you know most everybody of the top
performers has like one oh you know oh you know like um it's funny in my head i think when people
always act like google is like super hardened i'm always like yeah i agree with you but yeah there's
bugs to be found there but when you say something like that it's like maybe maybe maybe justin is
right maybe these people are right that google's pretty hardened yeah i think it's hardened i think it's
hardened in a different way though i think i think they use a lot of measures that that like prevent the
mega crits right and uh and but i do think there's still a decent amount of like mediums and and stuff
like mediums and highs to be found so yeah um okay let's jump back to this one um i'm gonna answer this
one what is the background behind starting ctbb and how profitable has it been and what is the long-term
plan interesting man interesting yeah i'm surprised you highlighted that one
yeah so the background to be a little vulnerable here yeah the background behind starting ct bb was joel
and i um who was my original co-host we loved the conversations we were having at live hacking events
with other top tier hunters and we wanted that all the time and so we wanted to build a podcast where you
can tune in every week and hear top top tier hunters um talk about their day-to-day existence and the
things they're passionate about in technology and and the bugs that they find and and share some of that
like hype energy um so that's that's the concept the north star of critical thinking is to bring and
that's why i added that you know pre-announcement at the beginning of this episode is to bring top
tier hackers one like actionable takeaway that affects their methodology positively per per episode
at least at least at least um and we're going to continue to try to do that um as far as how profitable
it has been i'm not going to give you an exact number but it was around seven or eight percent of my
income uh for 2025 um and this is the first year no i guess it was a little bit profitable last year
um this is the first year that it has been like you know move the needle at all profitable yeah um and
then what is your long-term plan um yeah it's an interesting question uh i think i i really love
ctbb one of the things that is interesting for me is that um it does take away the 100 freedom that
you have as being a full-time hunter right like i've still got to ship a piece of content
every single week to you guys you know and uh that is that is a burden i'm not gonna lie uh it really
is and and i want it to be high quality and i want it to be you know to move the needle for top tier
hunters so um as far as my long-term plan i think that's still up in the air for the time being i'm
i'm definitely going to keep doing the podcast we're bringing on other top tier hunters like rezo and
grep me um to co-host um i think as long as i am actively involved in the in the bug bounty world
i would like to be doing the podcast as well um we'll see one of the things we have talked about is
like adjusting the frequency or adjusting like um the you know how often i particularly appear on the
episodes um but for the time being we're locked and loaded for the long term we're ready to roll and
we're going to keep adding value to the to the hackers every week maybe ai will come still all
our jobs and then we don't have to do it anymore you know yeah well i mean you know i just all i've got
to do is train justin ai now and just have him show up on the podcast and be like guys look at this bug
you know and then my my hand is going to glitch out and you know it's going to like go through my face or
something you know um we need somebody in the community to make an af fully ai generated episode
just for the lols dude don't put it into notebook l lm man that thing's going to be like you know it's
going to be bad that's funny all right um you want to jump down to learning and getting started
yeah okay um this is interesting i would like to ask you this one is it worth finding a mentor if you've
only earned 3.3k usd and don't have any shit so i mean the mentor i i have always disliked the term
mentor i think you actually like it more than i do you've had lots of mentees and a lot of people kind
of view you as their mentor um i've always just felt like just be my friend like let's just let's just
collab and be my friend i like i think that like um you know i hate being under authority and i don't love
uh feeling like less than or more than anyone and so you know for me it's like hey let's just be
friends and let's just like talk about this lead you have or talk about these bugs you have um and you
know i'm not always available so message other people with the same stuff and that's totally fine
that's what i did basically i never had like a formal mentor or anything but i definitely reached
out to lots of friends in the industry and made friends you know to kind of fill that gap for me i will
say if you've found three thousand dollars in bugs like great job there are so many people out there
who have not gotten started or have never made any money from bug bounty um i would say look at what
worked for you like go back and look at how you know how did you find those bugs what company was it on
what types of bugs are you looking for you know how did you know do you have a ton of other dupes
because you're doing something different that doesn't work and then you should focus on what does work
um in general i think that that's kind of where my mind goes yeah yeah i i think just addressing the
point about like feeling above or or below someone i think that's an interesting point that's not as
compatible with like hacker culture than uh you know as a lot of things i would say i do like that
position because it does allow me to just like give you a little bit of tough love and really that that
is what i do with a lot of my mentees i say like look here's the deal man my job you know as your mentor is
to tell you how to win at this okay and what you need to do is this and you're not doing that so you
need to do it or you need to you know get real with yourself that you're not willing to do it you
know yeah and whereas someone hasn't asked to be your mentee or if that relationship is not
established you wouldn't say that to some like random friend probably right you know like i mean
i don't know maybe i would you know i yeah but you're a unique breed i think i think you're right
though that most people probably if they want that kind of tough love and like really great advice
maybe they do need somebody who's in more of like a mentor role yeah that does get me in hot water with
some of my friends sometimes is there are just people out there that are just not as you know
ambitious or you know or and and i try to tell them like hey you know the reason that you're not in a
better spot and the reason you're frustrated is you're not doing xyz you know and then they are
they don't want to hear that um which is their right you know and maybe i i i shouldn't do that
without asking that's what my wife has told me but also you know i've seen that produce really good
fruit in people's lives um so i guess my yes or no on this is is it worth finding a mentor um
you know a lot of the time what i say about mentoring and bug bounty is that it can be a double-edged
sword like you really need to learn how to learn on your own to be a bug bounty hunter more than almost
anything else you know almost any other industry you can get a mentor and that will guide you you
know that will help you and accelerate you in bug bounty it can really be a bad thing too um
and in and make you not you know excel as fast as you would if you just learned how to learn on your
own so um i think it's a personal choice um if you already have found some success by yourself
i don't know that i would call 3.3k since mid-2023 a decent amount of success
um but yeah i mean clearly you you know found at least one or two bugs i know i didn't realize it
was over three years yeah i'm just looking at the uh reworded questions yeah yeah um you may want to
you may want to look at what you did right in those reports and try to reproduce that um
and if you have somebody you know who's willing to mentor you then maybe great but i would say probably not
yeah and i do think you know i'm i'm we obviously use ai as a buzzword a lot i do especially but i do
think that these new top models really do make great mentors like if like i mean at least they fill them
into a role of like hey um i'm looking at this i don't know what to try next right or i'm looking at
this it's a great place if it's vulnerable i'm looking at this and i'm curious if it like matches
the rfc i'm looking at this and like i just i just need your help to like figure out like breakthrough
like give me some ideas for like ways to bypass this regular expression you know i think that like
we now have like an unlimited brainstorming partner through chad gpt or claude or whatever so
that's a really good point i really like that um yeah thanks for that question solid samurai best of
luck on your journey um what you got next um i really i really like this how do you conquer a class
for some reason it evoked like the class of um in like video games like how did you conquer this skill
how did you map this skill tree perfectly like it says like justin did with client side hacking
um and so i think that's a good question yeah how do you think that you conquer like a specific niche or
you know category of vulnerabilities okay so that's the question here by zen apparition now my question
is long and about how to conquer a class um here's what he's been going through and doing
that you're going through and you're going through that you're going through and you're going through
and you're going through and you're going through and you're going through and you're going through
yeah i mean i'm i'm looking at this and it looks pretty good yeah if you're if you're the type of person who's going to type out
this long of a question and the list of your um strategy you're probably already on the right path yeah and it's it's hitting a lot of the right areas so i'll read a little bit out loud for the audio
listeners he's saying here's what i did so far created a personal dashboard to get you know grasp
with html css js started learning about dynamic analysis learning client-side issues cspt xss iframes sync
sources you know all those sort of thing getting a good grasp by port swigger labs in a playground
pick a program fill measurably um you know nothing like what i learned hardly able to make any other sense
of anything and then repeat it right and i'm like yeah that that that makes sense you know you got to
do the repeat it part i do think this person might be somebody who's falling into over learning those
first four those first four points feel more like over learning like i think that the they need to just
stick with the fail miserably just keep failing miserably yeah as many hours as you can for the next
month and you'll probably stop failing miserably and you'll probably start finding stuff yeah yeah i think
that's definitely a possibility um it's hard to know where to draw the line for these people you know
and say like hey you're over learning or you're not over learning but really i would really leverage
on the side of like let me try to figure this website out that's right in front of me you know that's
an actual target yeah right um and it doesn't feel like you do have to thread the needle with like
uh hardened programs yeah maybe it makes sense to try to go with like lower paying programs for this for a
person who's trying to um build up their front-end skills like that yeah i i think
this is i i think a good summary of that which is like you need to learn on the target that you're
hacking on right so like if you if you're looking at a target in front of you and you don't understand
something or you feel like there could be the potential for a vulnerability you can go learn about
that vulnerability to supplement your attack with this specific target right but it's got to be goal
oriented for the specific target right so that's where you kind of mix the actual hacking and the
learning together right does that make sense yep it does yeah i like that question um thank you zen
apparition um okay um this one's from lunar oracle it feels a little funny reading the anonymized names
yeah yeah it is you've covered a lot of different angles on the episodes some feel like real gold mines
while others less so do you actually use all of these angles in your own workflows it seems exhausting
to apply all of them that's a great question yeah i would say for me personally definitely not you
know i mean it feels almost impossible um i do think though um having the tools in the tool set that you
know to recall um is something that justin has mentioned before it's like you don't need to
necessarily be an expert in it but when you see the thing it should trigger your mind to be like oh i need
to go look up that thing whether that be a cheat sheet whether that be that video that you need to go rewatch
that segment of whether you just remember that it was franz rosen that did it and you need to dm him
right like i think um those little associations in your mind with different parts of an app or different
types of vulnerabilities or different headers or gadgets like just um knowing enough and remembering
enough from the episode to be able to go reference them is like a huge part of the value yeah totally
agree there i certainly don't implement everything we've talked about on the podcast um i think with
ai stuff i will a little bit more now you know where i can just say to shift you know hey try this this
this this this this this this right um and i don't have to manually go do it um yeah but it's in there
you know it's in my it's in my brain you know and and uh uh just like you said you know being able to
go grab that piece of information when you need it i think is really helpful for a more advanced you know
hacker so yeah i do think there are some people though um for whom and for me especially when i first got
started that following methodology really did help yeah like it was just like what do i do next oh just
check the step just check check the flow diagram you know or check check the steps it's like oh what
do i do next okay yeah what do i do next okay and then it's like now i have these interesting endpoints
what do i do on them okay well i check all of them in every parameter for idor and then i check all of
them and every parameter for xss you know it's like it doesn't really make sense like i'm checking an api
response that's a that's application json for xss and it doesn't and it would never fire but it's like
it's giving me something to do right and maybe if it and maybe if i maybe if i did get a payload in i
would be like oh why isn't this working and then i would learn that it's not going to fire because
it's coming back as application json right and so i do think sometimes when you're beginning um
methodologies can actually be helpful so i mean if you wanted to go through the episodes and come up with a
methodology especially if it was through all the episodes or usually i have to do that i think
that'd be really cool if a listener created like a ctbb methodology based on really cool techniques
that have been mentioned by our community and on the episodes but yeah yeah yeah we have so many
transcripts on the website uh so i'm sure that there's a lot of data out there to be to be utilized
yeah um all right i can ask you the next one so yeah what's the next one here what's the best
approach when starting on a new target generalism or looking for a specific vulnerability type
okay um we could fly over some of these like easier ones like we've answered that you know plenty
of times in previous episodes yeah yeah i mean i'm just gonna give it really quickly um it's gonna be
generalism you know uh in my opinion because you need to understand what the target is is vulnerable
to and not every target's gonna have access you know yeah so if you're gonna do a specific
vulnerability type thing i think you need to be open to looking at a lot of programs and what you do
is you just say hey my i'm i'm like aggressively trying to learn ssrf this month so what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna spend four hours every morning i'm gonna switch my targets one time per day and i'm
gonna go look for these things but you're going to be less successful that way it's not going to work
out that well for you but you might learn more about that that about that um vulnerability type to
then apply to programs later when you do run across them so yeah and i think the the telling thing here
is what is their question their question is what's the best approach when starting a new target and
actually let's go let's go look at the yeah what would you say is the best approach when starting a
new target is what he actually says here rather than the ai summary yeah um the answer to that is
definitely generalism you know but but if you're if your question is what's the best way to make money
then you know then it gets a little bit different right well you know could be just check eye door on
every single program right i mean that worked for his link clearly yeah yeah exactly right um so yeah
i i think that it really you got to be careful with the question you're asking here um yeah if you
want to own a specific target you have to be a journalist because you don't know what's going to be
vulnerable there yeah yeah and if you want to be a beast right like if you want to be able to hack
anything you know then you got to know a lot of stuff right yeah um or but you know one of one of
we're going to have um uh zwink on or what was he now the idorminator or something later yeah yeah um
we're gonna have him on later this month um and you know one of the one of the big pieces of his
presence on twitter right now has been i'm not a great hacker you know he's like all i do is just swap
you know one two three four five into all of this stuff right and that's how i you know print money
obviously you know he's understating it a little bit but um you know i think there's some truth to
that where you know you follow the patterns that work and you can get results in bug bounty but if
your goal is to be the web hacker that can destroy any target that is a different different goal than
i want to print money in bug bounty yeah yeah and i think it really applies to the second question
uh which i i thought was um interestingly asked but had we you know we kind of reframed it it was like
tips for making half a million dollars from bug bounty in a year as an experienced hacker
yeah and you know the question i kind of reframed it to when we were talking before the pod was
what would it require of a bug bounty hunter to make 500k in a year
it's tricky yeah yeah i think that now that's a that's a really good question because most bug
hunters want to make more money right but as all things are in life it's a trade-off like maybe it would require of you to to hack 12 hours a day
maybe it would require of you to um i don't know learn new things you haven't learned before you
know or push into things you haven't learned before or maybe it would require you to interface with like
you know go and like ask other people to learn from them and ask them to collaborate and you know like
there are a lot there are a lot of um opportunities today because we have access to people and information
more than ever before but it would require a ton of work yeah yeah i think i think so um
this would put you in like the top you know point something percent of hunters
if you did this definitely in the top one percent um i think it's not enough really to
well yeah i think you got to go i think you have to have strong capabilities and at least
a couple types of vulnerabilities and you either have to well let me let me give it a little bit
of nuance to this answer okay i think first you need to go after programs that are going to pay you
good money so like yeah but see that's not even true because look at douglas right you know douglas
douglas goes after a bunch of little programs you know i think it's good money i think yeah i think
that that was true historically but i still think if you looked at his average bounties they would be
significant you know yeah okay like you know like we talked about our numbers last um last week or in
the last couple weeks you know and you and i both were around 100 bugs i don't think that he's in like
the 600 bug range i think he's in like the two or three hundred bug range right so i still think that
there's still a lot of you know quality that is still there but there's no doubt that if you're
making 500k a year your average daily value this is assuming you work weekends is 1400 so you have
to make one thousand dollars one thousand four hundred dollars in bounties every day on average
right and so if you actually want to do that it's going to require a ton of work you're going to be
dismissing like either crazy crits every couple days or one bug a day that's a medium or high right
and so it's a lot of work yeah or and here's the or there you got to go after some crazy crazy bugs
yeah you know you got to find some high five figure six figure bugs you know um to try to make up for
those days when you can't hunt um man you know unfortunately there's a lot of ways to do it here's
here's my recipe though i would recommend
hacking on programs that are going to pay you a decent amount of money um focusing really hard
going deep on those programs and focusing on the assets that are going to have you know obvious
impact to the the program um you need to be pretty effective in your hunting you need to not be
trying a lot of things that don't have possibilities of working you need to be like churning out valid
attack vectors that have a decent lehigh chance of working um and you need to know how to follow
these opportunities when you see them you know that might play out for these bigger bugs i think
and you need to write good reports yeah yeah so you don't lose yourself in in the the whole like
arguing with triage thing i agree um good question quick seeker thank you um all right
does ai and vibe coding introduce a new era of bug bounty hunting with more bugs to find uh dusk from
dusk grader give me a quick answer on this yeah we kind of we kind of talked about that i definitely
think um that we're in the aslop era of bugs i think that in a year or two ai systems are going to be
writing way fewer bugs right and right now we've got tons of people writing tons of apps using adderite
code nearly everyone i know who works at big companies also using added code and it's not great at thinking
about things like business logic idor those sort of things so i definitely think that it um introduces
a new era and on top of that me and lots of friends are finding vulnerabilities in um new ai apps right
there are there are actually like new types of vulnerabilities and then i think we have crazy
people like um arc arc was that their name um yeah yeah yeah yeah finding insane vectors like that and so
uh it does feel like a little bit of a new era in my opinion and so i think there would you know there
will be lots of lots of vulnerabilities in that way yeah totally agree with you there um let's move to
this next one from tenacious outlaw yeah um our ai summary of that says why are you in the human in the
loop plus ai camp while rezo is in more of the ai will solve web security camp um is this an actual
accurate representation of your perspective i mean probably not but i'm super happy to defend it i do
think that there is a tipping point at which it's cheaper to run you know a hackbot than the amount of
vulnerability uh or sorry bug bounty payouts that come out of that system and then you can scale it
infinitely and you know i always call that like the oh i don't even remember what i call it now but
the apocalypse for bug bounty no no no no yeah but you know and that's going to happen a few different
times right because then you run it and then once those bugs are found then it doesn't the tipping
point's not there anymore so you have to improve your hackbot and then you can run it again and so i
do think that that can happen kind of like um at some point but i do think that human in the loop is
going to be huge right like the reason why you're able to quickly find that bug that you talked about
during your presentation forward to hum con was because you pointed it at something that you saw
was potentially vulnerable right like your human intuition pointed directly at the thing that was
vulnerable when you could have i mean how many things could you have pointed at how many headers
were in that request how many requests did that make right you pointed it at that request with that
header and asked it to volunteer so there's no doubt that it's both and but uh yeah yeah it's interesting
because if it scales infinitely right like if compute just becomes like super duper duper cheap you can
just run it on everything you can just say every single cookie like try to hack it you know with this
you know and and uh and i think that will be a weird spot you know um but overall i think for the next
five ten years human in the loop plus ai is going to be massive at least um yeah um all right let's look
at some of these ones here um when you open a new program without tools what exact questions are you
asking yourself to mentally map the attack surface this is from silent dragon let me see if i can find
that one over here um i'm i'm really trying to emulate the user yeah it says when you open a new program
and intentionally delay using any tools it's like the actual question yeah yeah yeah yeah i i think
i think that i'm really trying to emulate the user you know like i'm really trying to put myself in their
shoes you know it's funny i i i did acting in musical theater in uh in high school and i think a little
bit of this helps you know like i think i'm like all right now i am the user of this app you know embody
that character let's go you know like and and you try to come up with you know what kind of stuff the
end user would be doing and what goals they might have and you try to use that to learn about the app
um what about you what do you think yeah i i mean i think something similar i do think i'm like you
know less strong at that like i have less discipline a lot of times i'll get in there and just like
get right pitch and hold on like interesting requests and stuff rather than like going through
the time to like fully use the app end to end in a way that a user would um and i think that does hinder
me deeper into live events where you know you want to get to the functionality that only 10 of
people are looking at right um by by doing that exact thing right setting up this you know video
game front store including all of the assets and all of the uploads and the patches and all the
things right to like really see that actual functionality um but yeah i mean yeah it's a simple
question i think your answer was fantastic their follow-up question is the interesting one though
we talked about that are there any specific mental anti-patterns you learn to avoid that look
smart but consistently waste time yeah that is a good question that that might take question of dama
i i think that's a really good question um i think one that we talk about all the time is eternal
learning and eternal recon right like you know it seems to make sense for you to like all right i need
to learn a lot of stuff about bug bounty right and uh i need to learn or i need to try to find the most
vulnerable assets so i'm going to spend a good amount of time on recon really it's not it's not what
you're what you should do you know it's a pitfall really what you should do is is get in there focus
on the main app focus on in my opinion this is my opinion a lot of people have different opinions but
um especially spending too much time on recon is is going to be really bad for hunters and and it really
poisons them too um i've got i've got a couple people i've worked with that are just really stuck
in the recon world and it's hard to pull them out um i think because i've been there i've been there and
i actually made it work you know for a long time i do more of both now but i think the reason why it's
so addicting is because it's like gambling it's like panning for gold and when you find that gold you
know and all hacking all hacking kind of is but there's like it just feels like manual hacking is
more of like the hard work like you've got to pick and you're like hitting the rock looking for gold
it feels like recon it feels like you're just like like it's more like panning you know you just
shove it down in the water and see if something's there shove it in the water and see if something's
it's like not as hard yeah yeah it's like it's like mining versus panning but all of bug bounty is
kind of like gambling you know like it is you know it really is so yeah i think it's i think it's just a
pitfall personally and then the other one that i had was writing actually everything down you know like
i've seen i mean obviously there are people like brandon you know grab me who um make a lot of progress
and they're hunting based off of taking good notes and you know that's how they integrate with their mind
i've seen a couple hackers that just literally write everything i think that is not good i think
there's some way you need to try to trust your intuition and your vibe on the target um to really
be effective about it and and especially if you're taking a lot of time to like actually write it out
like i don't know if that's a good use of your time i had another anti-pattern that came to me
whenever we were reading the question just now that i think that you're going to love to talk about
because you're so good at doing the opposite how would you define the anti-pattern of pigeonholing
like i think that you're like ruthless in your prioritization of your time and i don't see that
in other hackers and i think it hinders them it hinders me sometimes it's how would you like
define that class of or that that class of anti-pattern i think sometimes people can feel intellectual like
trying a thousand payloads on a parameter sometimes when they just need to move on you know yeah but i
don't know yeah i don't know man i mean a lot of that's hacker intuition and experience right um i
don't know what to say beyond besides that i feel like most people suffer from the inverse problem more
than the pigeonholing problem okay well here's the thing we were sitting in tokyo yeah we ended up winning
mvh yeah but you you looked at me and kieran you're like stop working on that work on this
so what's what's the answer pattern you were breaking there
was it what was it like it's impact alignment too man i mean it really is yeah don't focus
on what's interesting or what's new focus on what is going to have the higher impact yeah or something
that's going to be vulnerable you know like like you know you you like you guys were looking at
something that was likely going to be vulnerable right but the impact in alignment with the goals of
the lhe was not as on point yeah um and like it was going to come out as a medium and it wasn't
something that it had the bonus on it or that they cared about or whatever exactly and and we had leads
in valid areas you know um so that's why i kind of redirected you guys there um and yeah i i think ruthless
alignment to impact you know what what the target what you need to accomplish with the target i think is
is a very high signal like trait um you know maybe um and it can be in alignment with pigeon pigeonholing
right just kind of going down you know super deep on something and hyper focusing on it but yeah i think
the the best way i found to do that in my life is ask myself like the question of if i do achieve what
i'm trying to achieve here what would the impact be because you can be trying things that even if it works
aren't going to be a bug or trying things if it does work would be a medium right because like you're
looking at something that's post auth and requires user interaction and you're just like
spending hours on this thing it's like dude even if you popped it it's going to be a medium at most
just move on yeah and and if and you know you've got to be honest with yourself about it too
because it's very easy to get googly eyes at these you know attack vectors sometimes and be like
no no this is a great bug this is a great bug all they've got to do is click 47 things you know like
yeah you know uh so definitely being honest with yourself about that is a big piece um yeah
i i i think i had one more one more thing on that um oh yeah the the thing i was going to say about
this is if you do find yourself maybe like rabbit holing or whatever um you may take a step forward in
the chain and and simulate you know this one piece being done if you can and and see if you actually
do have a valid bug like you know uh you know apply a match and replace rule or something assuming you're
able to bypass some yeah you know logic or whatever right um and see if you actually do have like a
valid bug with the whole chain before you go all the way down on this one piece that you need to break you
know yeah because a lot of times you'll have that aha moment and you say oh it wouldn't have worked
anyways now you just saved yourself so long exactly i think that's important yep great question silent
dragon um man his next question here too is really good what was one specific belief you had about bug
bounty that turned out to be wrong and once you dropped it your results noticeably changed
tricky i really liked the expo presentation where they outlined these for agents you know and i think
it was their defcon talk that they didn't actually get to give but they posted it on youtube afterwards
they highlighted specific breakthroughs that they have with the product i really like that um
i'm trying to identify one in particular i think that one thing that's interesting is that i would have
believed that there was more um variation in mindset but when you are at these live events and you're
sitting with other top hackers and they are they're thinking in the exact same terms as you like i've
had so many moments sitting there inside somebody's laptop and i'm starting to say now try this and
they're typing that exact thing or you see two other people do that one person's like oh you should
try this and the other person's already trying it um yeah and that to me makes it feel more achievable
it's like oh i'm not so distantly removed from this person and they're just like epically way better
than me and i can't do it i think that kind of um so i think imposter syndrome is a good is a good
answer to this question that they're asking um yeah it's like one thing that i believe was that i was
was not able to or you know whatever but in fact you actually can if you if you try yeah
i don't know if i have a specific belief that i felt like was near and dear to my heart that once i
dropped you know realized it was wrong um that i i saw the results change noticeably from like a
technical perspective i will say from a non-technical perspective i believed that i needed to be successful
in bug bounty to respect myself as a as a hacker you know i needed to be winning every live hacking event
and stuff like that and i think that's too much pressure and um i think once i put myself worth in
something else right you and i you know for you and i it's our relationship with jesus but for a lot of
other people it's it's their you know um it's their religion or it's their you know relationships or
their you know something more stable than bug bounty like bug bounty is just such a crappy thing to put
yourself worth in because it's so volatile you know um and there are incredible hackers that you don't see
that don't find bugs at events right like it's not yeah it's not a game where just because you
are skilled means you definitely will succeed there is like a little bit of an element of you know um
yeah of like where you chose to spend your time absolutely yeah so check yourself worth i think that
that's probably my best answer to that um all right let's let's take these last couple ones rapid
fire and wrap up this episode so we don't give uh richard too long an episode edit this week because
it's we're pushing it out last minute um how do you tackle small scope functionality i think you've
taken some small scope before with me with small scope i move on if i if it's small scope and i don't
feel like i'm an expert at it or i'm struggling i the the then actually it's kind of a tip for people
too who are starting bug bounty if something's not your cup of tea like you don't have to stay on it
like there's lots of other stuff you know justin has this like goal and desire to do well at events
even when the scope is crap and you know not everyone has to live by that same philosophy i
personally don't but i that's an admirable trait in justin but so i would just say you don't have to
but if you're going to how should they tackle it justin yeah i would say um i mean you've just got
to grasp at straws is pretty much the only thing i can tell you like find every little little oddity
or little like quirk that you can find and see what you can make out of it um and i think that's a little
fun you know to prove to yourself right i think sometimes especially if you're a little bit like
you're an intermediate upper intermediate hacker and you've got something you really want to pwn
like just banging your head into it until you pwn it is feels pretty good yeah um and as far as hitting
criticals sometimes the criticals aren't going to be there if the functionality is not there the critic
the criticals may not be there um but definitely try things you don't normally try think outside the box
really put yourselves in the shoes of the developer um and that's how you kind of work around these these
small scope targets yeah um all right let me ask you this one how long do you stay on one program
before moving to the new one joseph um if it's like an actual new program like a new invite or something
um i would say as short as a couple hours as long as you know a couple days i don't think that people
should be whipping themselves into locking into a new program for a long time i think that's a really bad
idea because oftentimes the companies will end up skirting around the bugs or having like a really
weird duping policy where all your stuff gets duped if it's like an anchor program for other hackers
that you know then i think going along on that's totally fine but if it is a new program i do not
recommend that in fact i would say it's better to um spend a few hours on it submit a couple bugs if you
have some and then go back to an anchor program or another new one and then if they treat you well
come back to it right or maybe it's worth your roi if it's like pretty vulnerable to go ahead and farm
it for two days or whatever but i would not at that point stress yourself out i would then move
on to something else until they've like kind of proven that they're going to treat you well
yeah i agree i think that's a good one um you do this one do you recommend using additional proxies
besides burp and kaito uh no i would recommend you use burp or kaito um i i would say that there's
a new one on the scene i don't know that i like consider this like an actual proxy or whatever but
rep plus i believe is the name of it it's a you know chrome extension that kind of tries to emulate
what these proxies are doing yeah uh but you can't write arbitrary http requests because of
limitations on like the fetch stack that they're using to send the request so it's a little tricky but
like if you were in a pickle you could try using that i think that um you know if you're doing
system type proxying like sometimes you need to proxy the whole system because you're i don't know
i've seen people use like other weird proxies for things like that like there are some
proxies that make it slightly easier to proxy your whole system or if you're on mobile or something
but no if you're doing web hacking um definitely use one of the mainstays you know we're big fans of
kaito these days yeah i'm wearing the t-shirt today nice dude very good yeah i think this one could be
interesting you know rep plus could be interesting for like quick and dirty stuff when you don't have
access to a full um a full you know kaito setup but uh it's not going to have a lot of the more robust
features that you might need um all right next one is how many programs do you recommend focusing on
at once joseph how many programs do you recommend focusing on at once it depends what you mean by
at once right i mean i have only one at once actually it's kind of frustrating whenever you
get message leads for other programs and you've already got like kaito or burt pulled up and you
don't want to like at least in kaito you can switch um projects pretty easily but it's still pretty
annoying to me i start like mixing my traffic and getting all those on if if it means like uh you
know over the course of like a few you know days or weeks this is like something we talked about in
our end of year episode my goal is to actually come up with some anchor programs this year rather
than than bouncing around what do you think yeah um i think i mean pretty much exclusively you got to
focus on one program yeah uh you know there are exceptions when yeah if you're spraying a
vulnerability like there's no cv it's like a one day and you know it's gonna get paid out and you're
gonna spray it across all programs that's different right but yeah yeah i agree i agree um how do you
pick up bug bounties after a long break this is super relevant to me yeah i'm back at work today
yeah tricky um you get curious you get hype you've triggered your love of bug bounty and you claw at
your computer desk you know like i don't know man i just love this shit like i like if i had a long
break i just try to focus on how passionate i am about all this um yeah i think that's my go-to i'm
usually super antsy to get back to it um i think i think grab me or somebody else maybe kieran monkey
somebody said that they will do a pen test to get back into it i i don't know if that necessarily
worked for me but yeah usually i'm like so antsy to get back to it that i want to that um i'm curious
though i did hear a really cool thing it was on the chris williamson podcast he was he was interviewing
kuberman and he said if you're about to go into a period of learning it's you want some boredom
beforehand and afterwards um you want the you want the boredom beforehand because if you've been like
scrolling tick tock reels you're not going to find this like technical content interesting yeah well
that's a great point right yeah and so if you have some opportunity to go for a walk without your phone
or whatever before you come to your desk to do some learning i think that's great and instead you want
some dead space afterwards to really process it i think those are both smart things i think that it
also could apply to bug bounty like if you've been starving yourself of dopamine for like 30 minutes
or an hour or something then when you get your computer and you start seeing like you know the
potential for money and these like http requests i think you're going to be more excited than if you've
just been watching a youtube video of like you know your favorite video game or whatever so i think that
that's like kind of like a fun little just like uh life hack there yeah that that is good i like that
put a little bit of boredom adjacent to it that's good yeah um all right i think the last one that we'll
do is when should you give up on a bug that's been ignored by triagers look i've like i'm gonna be
honest with you guys i've never had a bug that is actually valid be ignored by triagers for a long time
so if if the triagers are eternally you know forever ignoring your bug it's probably not a valid bug
yeah you you have either done an extremely poor job of articulating it or you've overinflated the the
severity in your mind and so it's actually a low and so they're just not getting to it because all
the other reports are much more important justin i hate to do this you did we did i only highlighted two
questions that i really wanted to answer and we didn't answer one of them oh no dude i'm sorry i jumped over
it my bad yeah good okay let me ask you this then yes what invisible elements in a report usually make
the difference between a 2k payout and a 20k payout all right so i have a lot to say here one i think
that you're yeah uniquely good at it i do think that it's something that worked well for me and my
advantage of like coming up in bug bounty but i think that the number one thing that jumps my mind is
just try to reproduce it via your steps once it's not that hard because you probably forgot something the
number of times that you know i've had to respond to an nmi or and like even if the triager only has to
request more information we report one time i think it honestly changes the way they view your report in their
head for some reason yeah it's like if they can very easily reproduce it instantly i think that it will
sometimes actually shade their opinion of the severity even if it ends up being the exact same
bug but they just had to send it back to you once because you left such a good step wow dude
yeah totally no that's yeah 100 like if you just forgot to tell them to like go into the profile and
then go click the edit button to get to that request that they needed they almost i think will just
subconsciously view that report as like less than because like they had to send it back to you for some
reason and so i would just say always reproduce your bug via the steps alone like play ignorant put
yourself in the shoes of the triager and justin's acting uh advice and then go in and just do the bug
one time one make sure it still works because sometimes i know you've had this happen you go back
to reproduce and it doesn't reproduce and you swap the cookies incorrectly or whatever so that's useful
to do in general to make sure you don't get a not applicable but when you're doing that you'll be like
oh i didn't tell them to click here before they clicked here in order to get that thing right
yeah i think that's a great point i think i think doubling down also into your poc you know giving
them a script where they run it and then it just outputs pii you know of other people like that that
just feels really bad you know it does yeah yeah so add poc and video if it's critical enough that it's
worth your time to do so yeah try to make it look as simple as possible to exploit you know because that
that's the obvious you know best scenario is stupid simple to exploit very high impact right and some
of the time you know it's it's complicated to exploit and high impact right and in those scenarios you
really want to automate the poc to make it look as simple as possible um so that could be a big a big
difference um the other thing that i can say is spending a good amount of time on your impact
assessment yeah describing what kind of data you can get what you can do with it don't just like pop
up an auth token you know a show say hey this is the auth token you know here's how you set it in your
browser and now you're authed as the user or you know here's this token i can swap it for this and now
i'm in this you know in this account right um yeah yeah i think i remember the first time that i had that
experience um was i had found a vulnerability that i was like i don't know maybe this is a medium or
something and i sent it to mayonnaise or my own eyes depending how you want to pronounce it and he was
like dude this is obviously critical here's how you have to articulate it to their team and he like
wrote out like two paragraphs for me that was like you know the impact that this has on the advertisers
when they're going to advertise this if they if this was disabled it would actually you know reduce
their earnings in the month by millions of dollars because these are the customers you know like just
getting into the nitty-gritty details for the actual impact there i think is something that you
do well and something that will result in much higher payouts yeah totally man okay cool that's
a wrap i'm sorry for skipping that one i did want to add at the end here uh viral element asks any good
worship songs you can recommend so for our christian listeners um one of the ones that my church has been
running uh is alive forever and amen by uh travis cuttrell which is super good that's a vibe um i don't
know man it's hard when you're when you're put on the spot i saw it here and i spent a second like
thinking about it does anything come to mind off the top of your head i honestly have never been a person
who remembers song names yeah or or even artist names but i will say that with me and the kids in the
car i've just been totally obsessed with forest frank for like weeks oh yeah like i the the the the uh
the messages are so deeply biblical but then it feels like a fun song that you can dance to or have
fun to um yeah and uh this is uh um anyways i also just love like big bass all of my friends had cars
with like big subsystems and so in the in the tesla model y has a really good bass and so i crank up
the bass and it just feels like i'm like you know jamming around zoom into to worship music so it's
sick but that's awesome man that feels great all right then i think that's a wrap on this episode
um thanks to everybody who submitted questions i don't know who you your actual handles are but
we tried to call you out as much as we could um appreciate you guys participating yeah absolutely go
check out bug bounty.forum yeah for sure all right peace peace and that's a wrap on this episode of
critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh
or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community
there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion happening there on top of masterclasses hack alongs
exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me
all right i'll see you there